Let's take a look at the first piece called the value proposition.
The value proposition answers the question what are you building and for who?
The value proposition says, "Hey, it's not about your ideal product,
it's about solving a problem or a need for a customer."
That is what pain are you solving, what gain are you creating,
and more importantly, who are your customers?
Now value proposition is a fancy word for what product or service are you building.
This is where you normally would list all your features and
here's all the speeds and feeds and benefits and whatever but we're really going to
be asking a different question than might have been used to.
It's not all about your technology. Your technology is just part of the value proposition.
Customers really don't care about your technology.
The customers are trying to solve a problem or fulfill a need.
By the way, we'll be talking about this for multiple lectures.
The difference between a problem and a need is--a problem is I have an accounting problem
or I want to use the word processor, and those type of products solve a problem,
but they are other things that human beings do--like I want to be entertained or I want to have a date.
There's just some basic hard wired social need or I want to communicate with my friends.
Like Facebook or Twitter. Those are needs. Needs are different than problems.
And by the way, if you could find products that solve needs, your total available market
as you'll see later is huge compared to I solve specific problems.